stinky people don't know they stink they
like the smell of their own stink our
stinky person here I was the person that
ended up talking to them who was it I'm
not going to say but the other two
people that were running that channel
didn't feel comfortable so I told them I
was like I pulled them aside I was like
Hey like this isn't a personal attack or
anything like that there's some
stinkiness but it seems like it's where
you've been so is there anything you can
do did it get resolved the next time we
shot I was like hey did your shower and
he's like oh yeah yeah and then I would
check in with the other two does he
smell better like no
I tried talking so I try to remove it
where it's not like your like labeling
them stinkman and then the sniffers I
try to remove it from s the sniffer
that's a good B hey come here got you
some deodorant a is rash next day I got
you some vegan deodorant those don't
work next day here's a fze bottle let me
spray you one time next day this is a
shower a personal shower heyy I'm sorry
you're fired it's hard man but
especially with the chick